warning this video may cause you to
never want to eat sugar ever again so
you might want to pause this video and
get your last dose before I reveal some
very interesting information and of
course the more aware you are of what
sugar does the less you're going to
consume it I watch people all the time
around me just consuming massive amounts
of sugar and I'm like oh my gosh how
could you possibly do that well it has
to do with awareness they just don't
know the effects now we probably all
know the effects with weight gain and
dental decay and fatty liver and high
cholesterol and acne and high blood
pressure increase candida infections and
lowered immune system
etc etc but there's some other things
that I want to share with you deep
inside your body that you need to know
about and it all relates to
most diseases are metabolic diseases
what does that mean metabolic diseases
it has to do with your metabolism and
when we're talking about metabolism
we're specifically talking about this
one
structure in our cells called the
mitochondria
mitochondrial dysfunction is responsible
for the majority of non-infectious
diseases dysfunctional mitochondria are
what's behind
cardiovascular disease cancer in fact
the cancer you have normal cells that
turn into cancer cells because of
damaged mitochondria it's impossible to
get cancer unless you have damage to the
mitochondria Alzheimer's which is Type 3
diabetes kidney liver disease
all of these General metabolic diseases
if you look closely at what's happening
as a Common Thread deep inside the cell
we have dysfunctional mitochondria there
are a lot of things that destroy the
mitochondria but at the top of the list
is sugar and foods that turn into sugar
very quickly like refined carbohydrates
like starches breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes
muffins things like that and when we
talk about sugar the majority sugar in
the U.S is beet sugar and the majority
of beets grown in the U.S are GMO so we
not only have this refined sugar we have
this
GMO type sugar which has traces of
glyphosate which is an herbicide which
I'm not going to even go there but I
just want to make you aware of that
also the amount of fructose that we
consume from drinks sodas high fructose
corn syrup is a lot different than
glucose okay so we have fructose which
is only metabolized by your liver all
the other cells in the body can't
metabolize this this fructose so when
you're consuming large amounts of
fructose you are overwhelming the liver
and overwhelming the mitochondria deep
in inside the liver and so if we compare
fructose to glucose glucose is actually
much better than fructose but you have
to realize even table sugar is half
glucose and half fructose honey the same
thing and when we consume this refined
sugar it's very very unnatural because
we don't have the normal antioxidants
that come from like the natural sugar
that with sugar cane or even that come
with fruit when you consume fruits which
is high in fructose so how does that
relate to the mitochondria
well this is what happens when you
consume a lot of sugar glucose or things
that turn into sugar what happens to the
mitochondria is becomes damaged okay now
the purpose of the mitochondria is to
turn fuel into energy with the help of
oxygen
and so now with a dysfunctional
mitochondria we now create a hypoxic low
level oxygen State and from that starts
to be created other oxygen molecules
that are very reactive to our bodies
without getting too technical the
category of these things are called Ross
and I don't want to get into
complexities but just realize that when
you have a mitochondria that is not able
to use the oxygen you start developing a
lot of oxidative free radicals and a lot
of things that create more damage and
they're crated because we don't have
that oxygen so their derivatives of
oxygen that are highly reactive and
damaging to your cells and so it's those
oxidating factors that create the
complications of glucose they create the
damage from diabetes for example they
create mutations inside the DNA of the
mitochondria mitochondria very
interesting they have their own DNA and
real quick the history of mitochondria
is their bacterial derived a long time
ago a bacteria morphed with cells to
form this symbiotic relationship that
apparently over a long period of time
ended up in our bodies so the
mitochondria the energy factories in our
cells actually originated from bacteria
and apparently we formed an agreement
with them that they specialize in
producing energy and we'll feed them
okay we'll eat and feed them and we'll
give them a home but they give this this
Focus Machinery to produce energy and
they also have their own DNA but when we
consume too much sugar we get damage of
the mitochondria we get hypoxia lack of
oxygen we get uh mutation within the DNA
of the mitochondria we get decreased
numbers of mitochondria we get a lack of
fuel produced by the mitochondria
starving off your cell cells as in
Alzheimer's for example if the
mitochondria can't work we can't produce
fuel for the cells and what happens in
cancer is the cell as a survival
mechanism gets its fuel outside the
mitochondria
in other places a different pathway it's
very rudimentary it's very uh crude and
there's not much energy generated from
that and so the cancer cells have to
compensate by hogging up as much fuel as
they can and sugar is one of the fuels
that they go after hardcore but there's
a tremendous amount of oxidative stress
they call it that's produced from these
damaged mitochondria and the oxidative
stress is kind of like this high level
of oxidation with at the same time a low
level of antioxidants and this is why
when you consume a lot of refined
carbohydrates you're getting in this
refinement process a lot of sugar but
without all the protective mechanisms
that normally come in nature like
antioxidants that can normally counter
all this oxidation and so that equals
inflammation cell damage and especially
damage to the mitochondria itself
there's something else that's really
interesting that happens when you
consume sugar you get a decrease in
what's called mitophy now what is
mitophagy well there's a condition
called autophagy which is the recycling
of old damaged cells and that's a good
thing because you your body goes into
the state where it can clean up damaged
mitochondria and replace them with new
mitochondria and then that that's a
really good thing to prevent cancer and
avoid all the complications that happen
with damaged mitochondria
but sugar inhibits that ability for your
body to recycle mitochondria and maybe
you've heard of the tests from diabetes
it's called A1C right that measures the
amount of damaged protein in your blood
that's heat damage hemoglobin
because when you combine all that high
level of sugar with the protein you
damage it that's called glycation so
that glycated protein that damaged
protein can't be cleaned up as
effectively with the sugar in your
bloodstream so that leads to a whole
bunch of problems and then now we have a
hypoxic state in the mitochondria which
increases the risk for getting cancer it
now has to generate a lot of lactic acid
that can build up in your cells you get
a severe deficiency of thymine B1
now B1 is probably one of the most
important nutrients in the mitochondria
to allow everything to work correctly
the more sugar you consume the more B1
or thymine that you need and so when you
consume a lot of sugar you deplete your
B1 reserves and what comes next is is
devastating especially in the case of a
diabetic their complication is
peripheral neuropathy mainly due to this
B1 deficiency that creates a lot of
nerve damage and so this is why one of
the great remedies for peripheral
neuropathy which
is the bottom of your feet becoming numb
or tingling or burning or your hands is
taking B1 B1 will pretty easily resolve
that that condition or at least that
complication from the high levels of
sugar but also with a B1 deficiency
there's a lot of other problems that
occur too an anxiety state a lot of
nervous tension a lot of excessive
thinking insomnia nerve damage in other
parts of the body and also damage in
certain parts of the brain that have to
do with memory and then another thing
that gets depleted in the mitochondria
from eating a lot of refined sugar is
zinc and zinc is also needed to make
sure your mitochondria are are
bulletproofed or protected and without
zinc you get dysfunctional mitochondria
so you just might want to think about
the next time you eat that Krispy Kreme
donut or that candy bar you have to just
be aware of what the sugar does to the
deeper mitochondria in the cells that
sets your body up for a Cascade of
issues down the road so the question now
is what can we do to improve the
mitochondria well the number one thing
you should do is go on a low carb diet
it's called the ketogenic diet cut out
sugar cut out these refined carbs you're
going to feel better immediately and
you'll probably find that you won't be
depleting your B1 anymore or your zinc
anymore and also there's other nutrients
that you won't be depleting anymore too
the next thing is exercise especially
High intense interval training but other
types of exercise will also be
beneficial to boost your mitochondria
and this brings up another point about
athletes that are doing all sorts of
like long distance marathons or
triathlons they typically consume a lot
of carbohydrates and a lot of sugar and
you might be saying well how come
they're able to do this with all that
Sugar well
exercise can overcompensate and exercise
alone stimulates the mitochondria
exercise protects the mitochondria now
of course I don't recommend that as you
know something that you can do to
continue to eat sugar because I know a
lot of athletes that when they consume
the sugar they have a lot of side
effects they have a lot of problems and
complications but the point is that
because exercise strengthens the
mitochondria it tends to nullify some of
the complications from the high level of
sugar now you might also be thinking
well what about the people
a hundred years ago they were a lot
healthier than we are now and yes they
were healthier but they weren't a lot
healthier but I will say in the last
probably 40 50 years the amount of sugar
has increased the amount of fructose has
increased the amount of snacking has
increased the amount of added sugar has
increased and all that has been
devastating but think about even like
several thousand years ago where people
eating healthier back then not
necessarily they've extracted these
mummies and they've looked at the teeth
and the arteries and the bones of
certain mummified bodies and they had
periodontal disease they had cavities
they had problems with their teeth
problems with arthritis and they
consumed a lot of flower products breads
so this is not necessarily just a new
thing that's been going on for a long
time now another thing that can help
improve your mitochondria if we were to
look at like cold water immersion or
cold therapy it's the cold therapy okay
they're very uncomfortable taking the
cold shower or the cold bath immersion
that can stimulate your mitochondria way
more than heat therapy or saunas can
simply because of how uncomfortable it
is and also how our bodies were
developed to survive during winter time
and actually increase more mitochondria
when we get cold nowadays everything's
become very very passive and comfortable
okay we get to eat to 24 7 we get to
stay in a really nice environment inside
our homes not out in the sun and by the
way being exposed to the sun does
increase your mitochondria and not
eating so frequently as in fasting
greatly stimulates your mitochondria
certain epigenetic shorter stressful
things can improve our mitochondria like
going into a higher altitude or training
in a higher altitude can stimulate your
mitochondria to adapt and become
stronger so a certain amount of stress
is good chronic stress can definitely
affect our monochondria in a negative
way insomnia lowers the mitochondria in
our body a good night rest can enhance
our mitochondria because we recover and
of course alcohol inhibits the
mitochondria but on the flip side you
can eat certain things that will
increase mitochondria like vital
nutrients there's a lot of different
plant-based chemicals Resveratrol
quercetin the phytonutrients in green
tea and garlic can all boost your
mitochondria not to mention the
dependency on just basic nutrients that
support the mitochondria there's this
thing in the mitochondria called the
Krebs cycle that maybe you've learned
about and I'll guarantee rarely anyone
understood it back then you'd have to
really play around with it to really the
grasp or wrap your wits around it
because it's a very complex
Machinery but the Simplicity is your
body's turning food into energy using
oxygen and to do that process you have
to go through a bunch of steps and your
body requires B1 B2 B3 B5 and coenzyme
Q10 and other nutrients but those are
some of the basic nutrients that support
the mitochondria so if you made it this
far you now have more Awareness on what
sugar does to probably one of the most
important parts of your cell called the
mitochondria and getting off sugar is
going to be extremely therapeutic to
your overall health because it's
something that you can do to actually
create Health to help bolster the
mitochondria versus in our Health Care
system which I'm still trying to find
the health in it because we don't really
create Health it's all about taking all
of these diseases that are really
metabolic in origin and treating them
with drugs which inhibit the function of
your mitochondria now since we're on the
topic of sugar I've created a lot of
videos in sugar but if you haven't seen
this one I think you're going to find it
very interesting I put it up right here